Khloe Kardashian shares a sexy bikini  shot of momager Kris Jenner that's the  fun of it the 33 year old reality star  took to social media on Saturday to  appreciate her fit mama posting this  bikini selfie of the 61 year old to  Instagram writing hashtag six kids and  bad it's never a dull moment Christmas  scene rocking a white bikini with black  detailing and paired the look with a  white knitted cover-up sans makeup and  ready for the beach  Kris is currently in the South of France  and has been yachting partying hanging  with her celeb pals and boyfriend Cory  gamble this is going to be a really  great week from zebra-print to her  barely there bikini Chris's vacay  fashion has been fabulous as ever it's  magical  [Music]